- [Voiceover] Hello Grammarians,
we're talking about irregular verbs.
That is to say that
verbs that aren't formed
like regular verbs.
And to give you a taste of
what regular verbs look like,
just as a refresher,
let's take the word walk.
Let's put it in the present tense.
Now normally under normal circumstances,
we'd wanna just add an ed to it
in order to form the simple past tense.
So we go from walk to walked.
We add this ed ending.
And it turns out that there
are a lot of irregular verbs
that also behave the same way.
When we make the past tense
we have this ed sound.
It's just that they're not represented
that way in the spelling.
I'll give you an example.
The present tense form of
the word to sleep is sleep.
And when we put it in past tense
it is not sleeped but slept.
The pt part of slept
does the same work as the ed
ending, for the regular plural.
So sleep becomes slept,
is the same as walk becomes walked.
Likewise keep becomes
kept, build becomes built,
spend becomes spent, leave becomes left,
leap becomes leapt and lose becomes lost.
So although these verbs
are all irregular verbs,
within their irregularity,
at least in this case
there is some common distinctions.
They're all still trying to
make the same sound as walked,
it just displays differently.
So it's not sleeped but slept,
not keeped but kept,
not builded but built,
not spended but spent,
not leaved but left,
not leaped but leapt, not losed but lost.
At least as it applies to
modern standard English.
And that my friends is the funky ed.
You can learn anything.
David out.